that's what's the point because now  after queen h6 we don't have to take  i mean if i go after bishop e2 d5 let's  say i'm  random i just i'm not  i don't want to think about it let's say  uh  check check on all knight f6 immediately  i know  yeah you're not lost but it's also  unclear if you're better knight f3  or c4 c4 c6  yeah yeah you're not yet but this is  playable like rapport would think this  is winning more or less  c4 d4 coming um  no no okay it's f5 oof and look at king  and feingold  oh draw great yeah no no big surprise  there  yeah i didn't want to go for b3 b3  it felt like a weird move and kayaking  goes for the draw this is not strategy  this is not what he had in mind  when he came to the game today this is  consequences  of mixing up the move order  like he wanted to play this